it came out recently or a little while
ago that you were
that a real steel disney plus series is
a possibility it's in development uh
there was nothing but positive reaction
to this news when it hit were you a
little bit surprised at the level of
interest
i mean i'll interrupt you i literally i
was sitting at the atom project mix the
day that story broke and i'm looking at
the dozens and dozens of
sites that picked up that story a story
about a possible show
based on a movie from a decade ago it
got more traction than some stories that
are about new business or more recent
movies and it was just confirmation of
what i have felt on twitter specifically
for years which is that
people have a love for
real steel that is certainly enduring
but very personal to them
very emotional for them and uh and so i
was already excited about this this
possibility of developing that world via
a series form for disney plus but the
way that story took off was like final
proof that oh wow the love is still
there the interest is still there now i
just got to tell the right story in the
right way well my question is when
something like that happens because
obviously the studios read the sites and
they see what people are writing
obviously there was interest behind the
scenes in the series but when it
explodes like that online and everyone's
talking about it do you all of a sudden
get a vibe from the studios like are
they calling like is there more movement
on something like that when all of a
sudden the reaction is so positive
i wouldn't say that you feel that
immediate uptick of interest on the part
of the studio
uh that may eventually be the case in
the form of how much of a budget do they
give the show but where you really felt
it where i felt it was
prior to that we were slowly reaching
out to some agents and writers hey you
want to write a real steel series the
day that story broke we shifted into
what we call the incoming call business
which is the business of you're sitting
back and your phone's ringing and it's
just incoming calls and it's agents
one after another saying my writer is
dying to write it can you meet with my
writer my writer has an idea and so it
shifted the dynamic of the search for a
writer and a take and it just became a
lot easier because suddenly the
volunteers and the ideas were flowing
our way um is there any movement in
terms of
having a writer or any sort of like do
you think it could be filming
it can't be filming this year do you
think it could be filming this year we
have now had
several actual writer pitch meetings we
are narrowing down
the search
and the
ideas behind the take
there's a lot of different ways to go
and it's a little bit daunting because
a lot of those ways are
valid and cool
and which one is the right one i'll go
back to something i said in our adam
project interview i'm just gonna have to
go with my gut about what is the right
one because there is no objective
arbiter of right and wrong and and so uh
i don't think we're gonna no because
even once we pick our writer we're then
opening a room we're breaking a whole
season of television so it's it's more
of a process um but we are definitely
making good headway now and the way the
news broke and took off has been a big
boon to the writer search